the New York Times unleashes a doozy of
a headline CNN defends antifa and review
last night's election results in Florida
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show Oh a lot to get to today as every
day but first let me mention to you that
you need to update your resume okay
let's be real about this your resume
it's decent that's good but it could
always be better because you need to be
adding skills all the time the idea that
you're gonna be a one company for 50
years and then retire with a gold watch
it's not true anymore and that's why you
need to be constantly adding skills to
your resume it gives you greater job
leverage it gives you greater pay
leverage and that's why you need skill
share skills shares an online learning
platform with over 20,000 classes in
business design technology and more you
can take classes in social media
marketing and illustration data science
mobile photography creative writing you
name it they've got it I've taken
classes in social media marketing it
myself from skill sure it is fantastic
their 45-minute class is taught by
experts whether you're trying to deepen
your professional skill set start a side
hustle or just explore a new passion
skill share is there to keep you
learning and thriving go check it out
right now and you get a special deal
join the millions of students already
learning at skill share by going to
skill share calm and you use slash
Shapiro's skill share calm slash prepare
you get two months of skill share for
just 99 cents that's right again skill
share is offering my listeners two
months of unlimited access to over
20,000 classes for just 99 cents again
skill shared comm slash appear to start
those two months now skill share calm
slash up hero make that resume better
again skill show calm slashing Shapiro
okay so the media are absolutely
destroying themselves on the shoals of
their own political bias the clearest
example this doesn't even have to do
with President Trump today the clearest
example of this has to do with the
scandal that is now plaguing the
Catholic Church now as I have said I
think it is very important to put in
context the fact that the Catholic
Church which has obviously an
institutional problem with the sexual
abuse of minors is not unique in this
way there are lots of institutions
across the United States and
internationally in which abuse of
children is looked it's sort of
overlooked by people in power
specifically to maintain the supposed
credibility of those institutions the
Catholic Church just happens to be those
prominence of them and I think for good
reason because the Catholic Church like
other religious institutions is seen and
should be seen as a higher moral arbiter
the fact is that the Catholic Church
stands at the precipice between
secularism and religion and Jews
Protestants people of all other faiths
persuasions should be deeply troubled by
what's happening inside the Catholic
Church well to recap the Catholic Church
basically was experiencing a serious
issue in which a Cardinal named
McCarrick was accused of the abuse of a
bunch of minors as well as with
homosexual activity with a bunch of
seminarians as well he was accused by
one of his by by an archbishop named
Carlo Maria Vigano he's that the
accusation is that the higher-ups at the
church particularly Pope Francis
basically covered all this up that he
knew about this and that Cardinal
McCarrick was put into essentially a
form of private excommunication almost
he was basically ordered to do prayer
and penance for the rest of his life by
Pope Benedict and then Francis took him
out of that made him a public figure
again that was the accusation that was
made by the ghan oh and all of this
matters because now the media are coming
out and they are defending the Pope
they're defending Pope Francis Pope
Francis refuses to comment on this he
has not confirmed or deny that he knew
that this Cardinal was engaged in
homosexual abuses inside the church he
and there are two forms of abuse
obviously there's homosexual abuses
because it's against Catholic canon law
for priests to engage in sexual activity
of any sort and then it's doubly against
canon law for them to engage in
homosexual activity and then it is
triply against canon law to engage in
all of that plus children
well now that it turns out the members
of the of the upper echelon of the
church Pope Francis's greatest defenders
are coming out in defending Pope Francis
not by saying that Pope Francis fights
this kind of stuff within the church on
a regular basis instead they're fighting
back by suggesting that Pope Francis
should be given a pass because Pope
Francis is to the left on politics
leading the way is Cardinal blase cupich
blaze Koopa is the is one of the
Archbishop's I believe over in Chicago
and he is you know deeply tied in with
that with Pope Francis particularly his
comments on the scandal are absolutely
disgusting the Pope has a bigger agenda
he's got to get on with other things of
talking about the environment and
protecting migrants and carrying on the
work of the church
we're not going to go down a rabbit hole
on this how insane is that statement hey
we're not gonna go down a rabbit hole on
stopping child molestation inside the
church we have to focus on greater
issues like climate change and illegal
immigration those are the bigger issues
not the sexual abuse of minors by people
in positions of authority supposedly
representing God and Jesus no no what it
really it has to do with is protecting
the Catholic Church from allegations
that would stop their progressive agenda
now I've been a critic a longtime critic
of Pope Francis I think a lot of
conservative Catholics have joined me in
that criticism or rather I have joined
them in that criticism the reality is
that Pope Francis is a liberation
theology to believe that the auspices of
the church ought to be used to push a
sort of proto Marxist economics as well
as a social liberalism when it comes to
issues various and sundry he's not
changed church doctrine with regard to
abortion but he's been incredibly soft
on LGBT issues particularly on the
social side he's also been
extraordinarily to the left on issues of
climate change economic redistribution
and illegal immigration that comment by
coup pitch is so telling the Cardinal
cupich to say that the Pope has a bigger
agenda he's got to get on with other
things like talking about the
environment and protecting migrants and
carrying on the work of the church
that's an insane statement
it's an insane how insane is that
statement that Babylon B which is a
parody website they printed a headline
two weeks ago in which they said Pope
defends himself from allegations of
cover-up of child molestation by
pointing to climate change work it was a
parody headline and then coupe which
actually said the parody headline and
prosecutors are saying now it's not just
this one Cardinal Vigano who's accusing
the Church of knowing about all this
according to a state attorney general in
Pennsylvania the Vatican knew about all
of this as well this according to
Reuters the Vatican knew of a cover-up
of child sex abuse by Roman Catholic
priests in Pennsylvania through secret
archives at bishops in the state shared
with church leaders in Rome according to
State Attorney General Josh Shapiro no
relation though Catholic Bishops in
Pennsylvania systematically denied the
sexual abuse of thousands of children
over a 70-year period they secretly
documented the cases and often sent
information on them to the Vatican
Shapiro told to national news shows
Shapiro first made the allegations
against the Vatican during an August
14th news conference to unveils a report
on a two-year investigation into how
Catholic clergymen in the state
allegedly groomed and sexually abused
children it was largely based on
documents from the archives kept by the
state's six diocese he said he said
quote there are specific examples
well when the abuse occurred the priests
would go the bishops would go and lie to
parishioners lied to law enforcement
lied to the public but then document all
the abuse in secret archives that noted
share often times with the Vatican
Shapiro did not comment on whether Pope
Francis or his predecessors knew of the
information again the allegation is by
Cardinal Vigano that Pope Francis knew
all about them Vigano over the weekend
published this 11 page public statement
talking about Pope Francis and Pope
Francis's willingness to overlook all of
this and calling on Francis to resign on
the grounds that Pope knew for years
about the sexual misconduct of Cardinal
McCarrick McDonald said he told the Pope
himself five years ago a little more
than three months after Francis election
and Francis reacted badly to that and
put pressure on him in the opposite
direction was actually angry at him for
having revealed any of this stuff George
waggles his senior fellow in Catholic
studies at the ethics and Public Policy
Center in Washington DC He said Pagano
is a loyal churchmen if he is making
these allegations now in calling for
Francis's resignation it is for the
gravest reasons now how are the media
treating all this you would imagine the
media might be a little upset and
normally the media are pretty upset when
it comes to Catholic priests abusing
children right there is a movie that
just won an Oscar based on this very
spotlight was based on the Boston Globe
uncovering hundreds of abuse cases in in
Massachusetts archdiocese so the media
have been all over sexual scandals
within the Catholic Church for good
reasons and bad good reasons because all
of that stuff should be uncovered and
all of it should be brought to light and
that stuff should be I mean it's evil
and people involved should be prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law the bad
is that it's pretty obvious there is a
disparate motivation in the media for
going after the Catholic Church as
opposed to say other religious
institutions that are more minority or
non religious institutions in which
sexual abuse has become a serious
problem like the American public schools
with all of that said the media were
were certainly attentive to this problem
inside the Catholic Church for years and
years and years and years and as I say
with good reason but in this particular
case they're not reacting they are not
reacting with the sort of outrage you
would normally see
rekted at the Catholic Church instead
their outreach is directed at the people
who are making the accusations they're
very upset with Cardinal Vigano they are
very upset with Catholics who are upset
with Pope Francis why because Pope
Francis must be protected at all costs
because Pope Francis is a political
leftist and this is a headline from
Reuters hey here it is I Philip pool
Ella defenders rally around the Pope
fewer conservatives escalating war
conservatives escalating war like really
that's the great fear here not the
Catholic Church covering up cases of
sexual abuse of minors not the violation
of Catholic canon law over and over and
over by top members of the church with
the knowledge of the top Vatican
hierarchy that's not the real issue here
the only real issue here is that Pope
Francis has fallen under assault this is
why folks don't trust the media and they
shouldn't trust the media because when
it comes to protecting their favorite
figures the media will rush to their
defense at the first available
opportunity whether it is Barack Obama
or Pope Francis they like Pope Francis
because they think that he is a liberal
when it comes to matters of
homosexuality and when it comes to
matters of climate change and when it
comes to matters of illegal immigration
and so they are rallying around Pope
Francis even though it now appears there
are significant credible allegations the
Pope Francis knew of malla station of
priests right that mountain that priests
were engaged in homosexual activities
part of this is that the media are
deeply uncomfortable with any attempt to
correlate the the problem of a
homosexual subculture inside the
Catholic Church and the problems of
targeting abuse of minors so the fact is
that Cardinal McCarrick the accusations
made by Pagano don't actually even
extend to the abuse of minors they just
extend to Vigano
basically having a bunch of homo sexual
affairs with seminarians and pressuring
those seminarians into sex the media
doesn't think that's a bad thing and so
they're angry that conservatives are
talking about that in the first place
they also are refusing to acknowledge
that there is in fact a correlation
between McKenna's activities in certain
areas and mechanics activities in other
areas and there are certain
uncomfortable truths that no one is
allowed to speak about the culture of
the church and the targeting
particularly of young males in in the
church they the reality is that he
disproportionate number of the victims
of sexual abuse for minors in the church
have been male which is a which is a
something that the media don't want to
talk about specifically because they
think that will then be used as a way to
club homosexuals and and and gay and
lesbian folks and tar them as innate
child molesters I don't think that has
to be done I think that you can point
out that there is a disparity in the
number of boys who've been abused in the
church and girls who have been abused in
the church without accusing all
homosexuals for example of wanting to
prey on children which is a bunch of
nonsense but the attempt to defend Pope
Francis is obviously very telling that
wasn't even the worst headline of the
day I'll give you the worst headline of
the day courtesy of the New York Times
in just a second but first let's talk
about managing your money betterment is
the best way to manage your money so the
reality is that if you are somebody who
has a full-time job and you just take
your money you stick in the bank you're
probably not managing your money the
best way you could be probably just
leaving it the bank account and hoping
that nothing happens to it but you could
be taking that money and you could be
allowing that money to grow and that's
what betterment helps you with they give
you technology designed to help you make
more from your investments unlimited
expert advice designed to help you make
smart financial decisions tax efficient
investing strategies that give you an
edge low transparent fees as well and
constant access to information and tools
that allow you to track progress toward
your goals so it's your online and
investment adviser you should feel like
a smart savvy investor I have a
financial advisor you should too and it
shouldn't cost you an arm and a leg
betterment helps you outsmart average
now investing does involve risk but Ben
Shapiro listeners can get up to one year
managed for free for more information
visit betterment comm slash capiro
that's betterment comm slash up here ob
et te RM ENT comm slash Shapiro again
this helps you manage your money in the
best possible way it's your online
financial advisor betterment helps you
outsmart average and get up to one year
manage for free at betterment comm slash
Shapiro that lets them know that we
selling you the worst headline of the
day was not the Reuters have mine
defenders rally around the Pope fear of
conservatives escalating war the worst
headline of the day was this from the
New York Times Vatican power struggle
burst into open as conservatives pounced
so this has become sort of a meme on the
right is that when you is that when the
media report on issues that are harmful
to the left it's never leftists within
the church defend Pope as he covers up
sexual abuse allegedly that's not the
headline headline isn't leftist in the
media cover for Pope as
under those allegations of sexual abuse
cover-ups that's not the line the line
is conservatives pounds so when it is a
grave sin on the part of somebody on the
Left it's conservatives pounds when it's
a grave sin on the part of somebody on
the right it's the conservative
committed the sin that's the way the
media covered these issues that's the
way the New York Times covers these
issues so when it's Duncan Hunter
involved in a corruption scandal then
it's representative Duncan Hunter of
California Republican involved in
corruption and then when it is a
Democrat when it's Senator Bob Menendez
from New Jersey when they're allegations
made about him of sexual abuse for
example or corruption when instead of it
saying allegations of corruption made
about Senator Bob Menendez it's
conservatives pounced on allegations
like why that news I'm so confused as to
why that's even news why is it news how
conservatives react to an allegation of
sexual abuse cover-up by the Pope isn't
the news the sexual abuse cover-up by
the Pope it's such an insane statement
you'd never see that in Reverse you
would never see liberals pounce as
allegations of Trump corruption mount
because then that puts the onus on
liberals to explain why they are
pouncing instead it's allegations of
Trump at the Trump corruption mount but
this is how the New York Times covers
the issue and here is the way that they
they have decided to cover this quote
since the start of his papacy Francis
has infuriated Catholic traditionalists
as he tries to nurture a more welcoming
Church and shifted away from culture war
issues whether abortion or homosexuality
who am I to judge the Pope famously said
when asked about gay priests that is the
first paragraph of a story about a pope
who is alleged who is alleged to have
covered up sexual abuse and malla
stationed inside the church the first
paragraph is about what a great guy Pope
Francis is for not paying attention to
social issues like abortion and
homosexuality is it possible that the
Pope's reason for ignoring some of those
issues is specifically because he does
want to focus on those quote unquote
bigger issues the left's likes and he
knows the media will help cover for him
that's not even the worst of the New
York Times article I'll get to that in
just a second so the New York Times
article continues says just how angry
his political and doctrinal enemies are
became clear this weekend when a caustic
letter published by the Vatican's former
top diplomat in the United States led to
homosexual occurrence in the Vatican
hierarchy for sexual abuse it called for
Francis's resignation accusing him of
covering up for a disgraced Cardinal
Theodore McCarrick that's an insane
statement how the focus is on how angry
they are oh wow look at these people
what's making them you mad bro that the
Pope was covering for sexual abuse
allegedly yes I'm angry yes Vigano was
angry yes conservatives inside the
church and liberals inside why is a
partisan issue why is the Pope covering
for sexual abuse a partisan issue by the
way it wouldn't be a partisan issue if
the Pope's name were Benedict
if the Pope's they were paul john paul
ii if it were john paul ii there would
not be any of this blowback from the new
york times because then it would be
targeting a conservative pope but
because we are targeting a pope whose
liberalizing on a bunch of issues the
new york times legs then it's all about
conservative pounds with the letter
reports in the New York Times released
in the middle of the Pope's visit to
Ireland an ideologically motivated
opposition has weaponized the church's
sex abuse crisis to threaten not only
Frances agenda but his entire papacy
weaponized that this is a word that the
New York Times using a lot lately so
we've heard from the New York Times that
the that conservatives are weaponizing
the First Amendment the Conservatives
are you know using the free speech part
of the First Amendment in order to push
their view whoo-hooo weaponizing the
First Amendment so the issue isn't that
the left wants to shut down the First
Amendment the issue is that the right is
quote-unquote weaponizing the First
Amendment now the issue isn't the
conservatives are trying to stop sexual
abuse inside the Vatican no now the
issue is that they are weaponizing
sexual abuse inside the Vatican it seems
to me that if you were gonna worry about
weaponizing sexual abuse maybe you want
to start with a Vatican hierarchy that
looked the other way and put abusive
priests back in positions to abuse more
children would that not be weaponizing
sexual assault against innocent people
it's not weaponizing sexual assault to
accuse people of covering up sexual
assault that's not weaponizing anything
that's called telling the truth
okay but what's the New York Times real
agenda it's the next sentence at the
very least it has returned the issue of
homosexuality in the Roman Catholic
Church which many conservatives are
convinced lies behind the abuse crisis
to the center of the debate well this is
really where the New Times gets
concerned what the New York Times is
deeply concerned about is that there's
gonna be a lot of talk about
homosexuality within the church and we
can't allow that we can't allow that now
what's weird about this is that
homosexuality is banned by the Catholic
Church at least homosexual activity is
and the Toleration of homosexual
activity and
the Catholic Church is a violation of
Catholic canon law and has been since
the inception of the Catholic Church
there's a 3,500 year tradition in
judeo-christian religion of banning
homosexual activity or at least opposing
homosexual activity it's pretty clear
here that what the New York Times really
wants is for the Catholic Church to
ignore to ignore the fact that there's a
violation of Catholic canon law going on
inside high levels of the priesthood the
New York Times has Vatican intrigues and
power struggles are nothing new but they
usually remain within the medieval walls
or fly over the heads of the Catholic
faithful around the globe this battle
however is being waged an exceptionally
open and brutal manner this is an
objective news story it's exceptionally
open and brutal how about the media
uncovering all these sex abuse scandals
in the first place was that
exceptionally open and brutal or was
that called good reporting that they
were supposed to do but exceptionally
open and brutal when it turns out that
this sort of thing ties it into a
homosexual subculture within the church
when the two correlate and again doesn't
mean causation when the to correlate
then the New York Times is more
interested in protecting the homosexual
subculture of the church than in
protecting children
hey that is what is going on here what
is going on is that the New York Times
and folks in the press are more
interested in protecting their social
agenda within the church than with
protecting children because it comes
down to a choice between targeting
people like mckarrick who apparently was
having sex with seminarians and
protecting children the mckarrick was
also abusing they would prefer to
preserve mckarrick at the cost of the
children that's all I can take away from
these press reports these accusations in
the letter remain unsubstantiated says
the New York Times really would they
treat them as unsubstantiated if they
were against Pope Benedict or to be on
the front page of every newspaper ever
asked Sunday night about their validity
Francis said he would not dignify them
with a response which is of course a non
response if that is dignifying them with
a response if I asked you if you
sexually abused children and I have a
credible allegation from people who know
you and you say I'm not gonna dignify
that with a response or I don't know I'm
not gonna say guess I'm not gonna say no
I think it's fair to say that we should
have some serious follow-up questions
they are serious as the New York Times
the Pope's vague answer has only
heightened public interest particularly
in the core accusation that he was told
about mr. McClaren's history of sexual
relations with seminarians and did
nothing about it but Francis is not
answers in keeping with his reluctance
to give oxygen to a small if influential
noisy group of conservative prey let's
and writers aligned with the author of
the letter so it's all a political war
that's all this is it's just a political
war and then I'm supposed to wonder that
people on the right don't trust the
media when they're willing to cover for
a pope who may indeed be covering up for
sexual abuse of children and seminarians
because they like the Pope's agenda
fully insane and that's not the limit of
how far the media went in the last
couple of days on a variety of issues
we'll get into their insane defensive
antiva in just a second but first let's
talk about your investments so Robin
Hood is an investing app that lets you
buy and sell stocks ETFs options crypto
currencies all commission-free
they are striving to make Financial
Services work for everyone not just for
wealthy folks so if you're into trading
you ought to be looking at Robin Hood
because there is no Commission fee other
brokerages charge up to ten bucks for
every trade Robin Hood doesn't charge
commission feeds you trade the stock
seemed to keep all your profits and it's
easy to understand because they use
these great charts and market data you
can place a trade in just four taps on
your smart phone I've looked at Robin
Hood I've seen how easy user-friendly it
is my assistant uses Robin Hood on a
regular basis she's into the trading go
check it out right now Robin Hood web
platform also lets you view stock
collections like 100 most popular
entertainment social media you can have
curated categories like female CEOs
analysts ratings a buy hold sell for
every single stock and you can learn how
to invest as you build your portfolio so
the best way to learn to invest is to
actually start investing go check it out
right now Robin Hood is giving listeners
a free stock like Apple Ford or Sprint
to help build that portfolio sign up at
Shapiro dot Robin Hood com
that's Shapiro dot Robin Hood common use
that Shapiro dot Robin Hoods Khan
website then you get a free stock like
Apple Ford or sprint go check it out
right now
Shapiro dot Robin Hood com it's the best
way to learn to trade and can do so
without them ripping you off on the
commissions go check it out right now
Shapiro dot Robin Hood comm an easier
more user-friendly way to trade okay so
it wasn't just that the media are now
covering for the Pope because they think
the climate change is more important
than the abuse of children or because
they think that the promotion of
homosexuality within the church is more
important than the abuse of children no
they are now covering for the media
because they believe that the media are
now covering not just for the Pope they
are also covering for groups like an
Tifa so the folks over at CNN seem to
have some bizarre love for anti fool
very seen
Cuomo in the past the the less smart or
more smarter the Cuomo brothers
depending on which data is we've already
seen him defendants he fat Don Lemon
last night on CNN defended an Tifa as
well and he fight you will recall is a
group of people who hold themselves
anti-fascist but then they dress up in
masks and beat the crap out of people
which is actually fascist here is Dom
lemon defending them it says it right in
the name and Tifa anti-fascism which is
what they were they're fighting listen
there's you know no organization is
perfect there was some violence no one
condones of violence but there were
different reasons for antifa and for
these neo-nazis to be there one racist
fascists the other group fighting racist
fashions there is a fascist there's a
distinction there okay that's insane I
love that he says it's right there in
the name right and the name Affordable
Care Act is right there in the name it
didn't make it affordable or care and
the air every act is named after
something it doesn't mean that it
actually is that thing and they're a
bunch of the the People's Republic of
North Korea is not actually a Republic
the USSR the Union of Soviet republics
that that's not actually a it was not
actually a union of Soviet republics it
was actually a dictatorship from the top
run by a one-party state so um no I love
that I love that he says antifa is its
anti-fascist therefore not every group
is perfect well I can say this groups
that I belong to don't go out in masks
with clubs and beat the living crap out
of people break ATMs and shatter windows
that's actually not the groups that I'm
a part of nor the groups that I support
and when those groups do do the due
diligence I'm aware I've never been a
member of any of those groups or back to
any of those groups I love that the Tea
Party were terrorists according to the
left but an Tifa who legitimately
requires six hundred police officers to
be prevented from shutting down a speech
I'm doing in Berkeley those people are
just you know just a few bad apples who
just always seemed to come to the
forefront every time an Tifa does any
sort of activity weird how that works is
it the same CNN that labels the Tea
Party a bunch of terrible awful violent
people when it's really a bunch of
six-year-old dudes with don't tread on
me flags that that's the clearly that's
the threat not not an Tifa I can't
imagine why we don't trust the media I
love this Allison Cameron
did an interview with John Sununu
Johnson and his former governor of New
Hampshire very close friends with John
McCain and this demonstrates again why
folks don't trust the media so John
Sununu doesn't trust the media and he
doesn't trust some of the headlines that
come out from the Washington Post or CNN
which he has every right not to do and
Allison camerata brings him on
supposedly to talk about the death of
his very close friend John McCain and
instead she starts to drill and grill
him about President Trump because the
only thing he's allowed to say on CNN is
that President Trump is garbage even
when he's there just to talk about John
McCain and folks don't trust CNN shock
or shocker you come on CNN and we
appreciate you coming on CNN and we
appreciate your take on it but I don't
appreciate you denigrating our reporting
I think that you know we have excellent
reporters here but are you saying that
you don't want to believe that you don't
want to believe that President Trump
would do that about I'm saying that I
don't want to comment on a report that I
haven't satisfied myself as correct okay
and then that I mean that's the way
CNN's gonna approach this any questions
about CNN are off the table by the way
CNN analyst Jeffrey Toobin yesterday
claims that any criticism antiva
was Donald Trump's appeal to racism hey
auntie feh is whiter than the local
branch of the KKK
I mean antiva is a bunch of what Oh
every time they're a bunch of arrested
auntie Farrelly is always a bunch of
white people so that's pretty
astonishing stuff from the media all of
which has driven a lot of the a lot of
the support for president Trump's trips
on the media so this was actually quite
funny yesterday President Trump was
meeting with the head of FIFA in FIFA
FIFA as a Soccer Association FIFA
account cow oh really Kerry thanks for
the correction Alex don't care okay but
the president was meeting with the head
of FIFA McFee FIFA the head of the
Soccer Association and he actually turns
to the press and gives them a red card
he's actually pretty funny yellow card
is a warning
and when you want to kick out someone he
started trying to throw them at the
members of the press he doesn't like the
members of the press
I think the Trump and the right are are
well justified in their dislike of a
dishonest press that reports issues like
an Tifa and the Catholic Church the way
that they do also the media's
malfeasance here drives a lot of fear
and that fear drives bad politics so
yesterday president Trump was excoriated
for statements that he made to members
of the angelical community as per NBC
News President Trump was talking to a
bunch of evangelical leaders at the
White House and he said the level of
hatred the level of Hank anger is
unbelievable
part of it is because of some of the
things I've done for you and for me and
for my family but I've done them this
November 6th election is very much a
referendum on not only me it's a
referendum on your religion it's a
referendum on free speech in the First
Amendment he said if the GOP loses they
will overturn everything that we've done
and they'll do it quickly and violently
and violently there's violence when you
look at antia and you look at some of
these groups these are violent people
well well I disagree that we're gonna
look at a violent overturning from the
bottom up of the First Amendment what I
do see from the left is that level of
anger and level of hatred directed at
religious people and it's very real
unless that religious person happens to
be somebody that that folks on the Left
believe is gonna overturn the the
priorities of conservatives if it's Pope
Francis then he has to be praised to the
skies and protected even if he is
covering up for sexual abuse if it is an
actual conservative then they will
attack that conservative up and down so
I think that the left ignores its own
role in driving the polarization they
like to pretend that Donald Trump the
universe began with Donald Trump with
the birth of Donald Trump the coverage
of the press in other areas of human
life including the coverage of the
church scandal or an Tifa demonstrates
that reactionary politics is alive and
well on both sides I think that this
fight was started by the left I don't
like how the right has responded to the
left but that doesn't mean that the left
didn't start this fight and that the
right doesn't have pretty good reason to
worry about the excesses of the left if
the left should ever take power speaking
of the excesses of the left
I mean you wonder why we don't trust
folks on the left to have power maybe
it's because they seriously write
articles like this I love this one it's
so astonishing is from Daisy Alioto over
at voxcom
so full disclosure I have a couple of
people with whom I am friendly at voxcom
but
overall boxes steaming pile of human
debris it is it is just an awful awful
website and they print garbage pieces on
a regular basis and in just a second I'm
going to give you the latest of the
garbage pieces but first let's talk
about you exercising your second
Amendment rights now I'm not just
talking about you going hunting or going
sport shooting or something like that
I'm talking about the real reason that
the founders wanted you have a gun but
just protect your family protect your
home protect your community and protect
your country well the folks who care the
most about that are the folks over at
Bravo company manufacturing it's
starting to garage by marine vet more
than two decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that actually
meets combat standards BCM believes the
same level of protection should be
provided to every American regardless of
whether you're a private citizen or a
professional if you have to protect
yourself you need a gun that works BCM
is not a sporting arms company they
design engineer and manufacture
life-saving equipment and they assume
that each rifle leaving their shop will
be used in a life-or-death situation by
a responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or soldier oversees every
components of a BCM rifle is hand
assembled and tested by Americans to a
life-saving standard of course they
apply by every applicable law and they
understand that if the time comes
somebody's in your house are gonna need
a gun that works BCM feels a moral
responsibility as Americans to provide
tools that will not fail the user when
we're not just talking about a paper
target it's somebody coming to do you
harm to learn more about Bravo company
manufacturing head on over to Bravo
Company MFG comm you can discover more
about their product special offers and
upcoming news that's Bravo Company MFG
comm again go check them out their
videos are really astonishing and quite
cool go check them out at youtube.com
slash Bravo Company USA this Bravo
Company MFG calm or youtube.com slash
Bravo Company USA these are folks who
know why we need guns and put together
exactly the kind of firearms that you
need if you got to protect yourself
Bravo Company MFG comm go check them out
right now okay in just a second I get to
them I've talked a lot about media
ridiculousness today but this one takes
the cake
I'll get to that in just a second $9.99
a month gets you a subscription to daily
wire the rest of this show live the rest
of clayvin show live the rest of
Knowles's show live if that's something
you're into plus with the annual
subscription you get this the very
greatest in all beverage vessels the
leftist here's hot or cold tumbler
refreshing to both mind and spirit as
well as body you can check that out
right now with your annual subscription
it's cheaper than the monthly so go
check that also when you subscribe over
at youtube
iTunes you got access to our Sunday
special this week our Sunday special
features one of my favorite authors
professor Edward phasor professor phasor
is the author of five proofs of God's
existence and a variety of other
philosophical books really good
philosopher and we talked about his
logical secularly based proofs of God's
existence and what we lack in a society
that doesn't believe in God anymore
professor ed phasor here's a little bit
of what we talked about hi I'm Edward
phasor the author of five proofs for the
existence of God and this Sunday on the
Ben Shapiro show Sundays special we be
talking about the book and about the
traditional arguments for the existence
of God and it is totally worthwhile it
is deep stuff I mean get ready I mean
get your scuba gear ready because we go
deep on this particular topic it's not
the easiest stuff but it is I think some
of the most informative stuff we've ever
done on the Sunday special so go check
that out right now we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
the most ridiculous story of the day
comes courtesy of as I say jay-z a
Liotta over at voxcom
here is the title the big problem with
the animal crackers cage free box
redesign so covered this a little bit
earlier this week animal crackers it's
Barnum's animal crackers it's based on
the circus now Barnum and Bailey Circus
is no longer operational because they no
longer use elephants and people stopped
going because it was supposedly cruel to
animals so they fixed the box to get rid
of the bars that were holding these
animals inside a circus or a zoo or
whatever and now the animals are sort of
randomly roaming free across the
Savannah in what looks like a
multicultural gang as like a zebra an
elephant a lion a giraffe it looks like
a band photo except for wild animals
from Africa and it's it's it's his new
look same great taste but it's so funny
folks on the left right people on the
right are really upset about this I
wasn't upset about it I just thought it
was hilarious and stupid that this was
like a top priority for folks on the
left and it and at PETA People for the
Ethical Treatment of Animals but folks
on the Left are actually upset about the
new Box redesign this is almost as
someone said online the Platonic ideal
of a voxcom article the big problem with
the animal crackers cage free box
redesign here's what it says Nabisco's
animal crackers are a staple of American
snack food aisles and the Box a red and
yellow rectangle featuring brightly
colored circus animals cavorting in
cages is instantly recognizable just
last week though Nabisco's parent
company Mandalay announced it will
change the design of the box instead of
depicting the animals behind the bars of
a circus wagon and will show them a
striding free along a savanna the change
is the result of a recent successful
lobbying effort by PETA which said no
living being exists simply to be a
spectacle or to perform tricks for human
entertainment yet all circuses and
traveling shows that use animals treat
them as mere props denying them
everything that's natural and important
to them so they had to change the the
box because PETA said that no living
being exists simply to be a spit a
spectacle or perform tricks for human
entertainment which ignores PETA which
exists solely to be a spectacle and
provide tricks for my entertainment now
the change is symbolic it stirs up some
mixed feelings for me ethics wise as
well as personally because the designer
of the previous box was my
great-grandfather's brother
swapping the art on the box doesn't
address the real issue PETA raises but
it does do a disservice to my uncle's
art and legacy my uncle's design was
about joy not cruelty
Times reports the design had been in
place since 1902 but according to the
papers own records commercial artist
Sidney's Stern my great granduncle
designed the recognizable packaging in
1923 uncle Sidney died in 1989 at age 99
two years before I was born so I never
got to meet him but I believe his design
wasn't about animal cruelty he was
thinking about joy a vintage poster for
his animal cracker design reads a circus
for children and shows the animals
marching out of the box Stern added a
polar bear to the box so it would have
more color variation and a string so the
box could be used as an ornament much
like his idea to call a new cracker
RIT's despite being the height of the
Great Depression his art thrived on
being a light in dark time his own life
was far from easy he was one of six
siblings raised by Hungarian immigrants
in a cramped tenement in lower Manhattan
and it goes on like this for a long but
this is the best part redesigning the
box doesn't remedy the inequalities in
play the inequalities on the animal
crackers box norms like those since
times have changed including the public
consensus around the prospect of animals
being abused for entertainment yet the
symbolic significance of changing the
animal cracker box does little to
dismantle the elements of capitalism
that exploit animals people and the
environment when art and advertising
bears the burden for corporate
malpractice the people involved in these
changes get to feel good but other
mechanisms continue to thrive under the
service under the surface this is the
best part
before she stepped down last year mondal
a CEO irene rosenfeld was making 402
times more than the company's median
worker according to the Chicago Tribune
at $17 11 that 17 point 11 million
dollars to the median of $42,000 in 2016
when monsley moved some of his
production to Mexico it claimed that
gave the workers union a choice between
moving and another option to chip away
at the 46 million year they would say by
moving a chance to save their jobs that
other option a 60 percent pay cut
according to the LA Times this level of
corporate greed cannot be fixed with the
new box design okay so they removed the
bars off the animals which is dumb
enough because now the animal is gonna
eat each other in fake land where people
care about these bars being in place in
the first place but now the real problem
is that by removing the bars from the
picture of the animal crackers box
we are underscoring the evils of
capitalism voxcom
at its absolute finest I
of it I love it so much she's this
office when I was writing about uncle
Sidney in 2016 for food and wine I was
able to get in touch with a former
corporate archivist at Kraft one of the
people responsible for maintaining the
company's historic records she said
after the merger there was no Nabisco
archivist and possibly no archive as far
as I know the best archive of
mid-century Nabisco box design is at
Uncle Sidney's home in New Jersey where
the artwork fills multiple rooms do you
know design the Campbell's soup label
probably not but you certainly know Andy
Warhol because he was a real artist if
you've seen Mad Men you know that
in-house artists and marketers often
work in teams many gifted artists
without the money to pursue a career in
fine arts turns a commercial art as
their day job and became nameless
contributors to the brand's public faced
they are the real victims the real
victims are all of the people who
actually made the logos for these for
these products society is set up so that
we have to make small ethical choices
because the biggest ones are too hard to
tackle now my uncle's art has become a
part of this cycle so if you see me at
the grocery store buying up remains of
his public legacy it's not because I
don't care about the Ethical Treatment
of Animals or people for that metal or
people for that matter it's because the
animal crackers box is my balfus Wow
voxcom
doing the work no one cares about
because it's stupid
speaking of media bias there's a story
that is worth noting here so there's a
lot of talk over the last year or so
about this case from April 29 2017 in
which a white Texas police officer was
found was shot to death
a black teenager named Jordan Edwards
this this officer and officer Tyler
gross
had responded to a report of drunk
juveniles and found teens leaving a
house party on the night in question
Oliver claimed that he saw a car moving
toward fellow officer Tyler gross
ignoring commands to stop fearing for
Gross's life Oliver said he fired at the
car where Edwards and other teens had
been riding and then Oliver told the
court he had heard what sounded like
gunshots when he arrived to the scene
and said people in the crowd were
fleeing and then he said that he shot
this this kid who was in the car officer
gross however testified that he was not
in fear for his life when Oliver fired
his weapon
additionally there was video showing the
car was really driving away from gross
not toward him and court records said
Oliver had flipped off the car Edwards
was in following the shooting this
officer was convicted of murder and will
now go to prison so for all the talk
about how racist the
justice system is this is a police
officer who shot a black kid wrongly and
will now go to prison for it that's why
when people say that we live in a KKK
system it's like no this is not a KKK
system this is a police officer in Texas
a very conservative state who was
convicted of shooting a kid because
there was evidence that he'd shot the
kid wrongfully that's how the system is
supposed to work and yet we are treated
to the spectacle of the media constantly
claiming that the reality is that
America is suffering from endemic racism
which can never be cured the latest
proof of that comes courtesy of this
election in Florida so the media is
making a very big deal of this election
down in Florida where Tallahassee mayor
Andrew Gilliam shocked his Democratic
rivals and won the nomination for
governor according to the Miami Herald
Democrat Andrew Gilliam wrote a surge of
liberal support from young people in
african-americans to a stunning primary
victory Tuesday and the historic
opportunity to be the first black
governor in Florida's history so I have
to say I'm a little underwhelmed by the
first black governor in Florida's
history kind of line of narrative given
that we've had the first black president
we've had black attorney generals black
secretaries of state black senators we
have I believe the only black senator
from the south and right now is actually
a Republican Tim Scott this is not a do
we have to do the first black everything
is this like a thing now yeah I guess so
I guess so but the implication seems to
be that the people of Florida are racist
so it's some sort of big shock and then
if he doesn't win presumably we will
suggest that it was because of the color
of his skin not because he's a political
radical with 94% of the votes counted
Gilliam had an unofficial three
percentage point lead over his closest
rival former US Representative Wayne
Graham when Graham's father of course
was was a senator from the state of
Florida as well so his program is
insanely far to the left he has called
for medicare-for-all just like Bernie
Sanders Bernie Sanders campaigned for
him and what we are seeing in a lot of
these primaries the real story of
gillum's win is not racial the real
story of gillum's win is that Bernie
Sanders in the far left in primaries do
have a lot of sway just as president
Trump has a lot of sway in Republican
primaries so the repository old race is
now going to feature this this guy
Andrew Gilliam versus Ron DeSantis who's
a congressperson down the line
conservative who happens to be very
friendly with President Trump and
President Trump has been very friendly
to him
Guilhem says he yearns for the chance to
take on De Santis in November - Sansa
says I think he is way way too liberal
for the state of Florida there's another
problem here because his agenda includes
a $15 an hour minimum wage staunch
opposition to the Stand Your Ground
self-defense law that exists in Florida
where if somebody attacks you you have a
right to defend yourself and Medicare
for all so this is what he supports
that's a pretty Left agenda but there's
a bigger problem and the media are going
to downplay it because he's a Democrat
so again when it's a Democrat then the
story is Republicans pounced when it's a
Republican then the story is Republican
corruption so this is a Republicans
pound story because the Andrew Gilliam
is actually under investigation by the
FBI for corruption or at least his City
mayor's mayor's offices according to
Tampa Bay comm the Tampa Bay Times
Andrew gillum's campaign for governor
hasn't been lucky as just a few months
into the Tallahassee mayor's run FBI
agents delivered a subpoena to his City
Hall in June 2017 requesting thousands
of pages of records from key players in
city government the investigation is dog
gillum's campaign with new developments
dripping out with unpredictable
frequency the FBI is usually
tight-lipped about pending matters
although Gilliam has not been named in
any subpoenas it's likely the Democratic
Party voters wouldn't know the cases
outcome before they head to the polls in
on August 28th and they didn't there was
no outcome before that starting in 2015
FBI agents came to town posing as
businessmen considering investments in
the city of Tallahassee the three men
who reportedly identified themselves as
Mike sweets Mike Miller and Brian Butler
spent months cozying up to city
officials and people close to them the
FBI investigation based in part on their
undercover work has yielded several
rounds of subpoenas but no charges yet a
slew of tallahassee tallahassee
officials and insiders have been named
in those subpoenas over the past year
according to those documents the part of
the investigation that could be most
relevant gilliam centers around the
city's Community Redevelopment Agency
which shares private and public money to
revitalization an infrastructure project
one of the officials in the crosshairs
of the FBI lobbyist Adam quarry was a
longtime gilliam friend and Ally until
Gilliam cut ties with him after all of
this started to come to the fore in 2013
the Community Redevelopment Agency voted
to give 1.3 million dollars in taxpayer
money topic ory associated a restaurant
project the Edison Gilliam voted with
the rest of the city commissioners to
fund the project at the time gillum's
vote raised
Brow's because of his close association
with Cory so we're gonna pretend that
this corruption doesn't actually exist
because Gilliam is a Democrat we're
going to meanwhile go after President
Trump on every available count that we
can possibly dig up against him before
the media but Gilliam will wait for all
the evidence to come in now should we
wait for the evidence to come in sure
but to pretend those allegations don't
exist is I think kind of telling about
the media's agenda in in all of this
should Gilliam lose to the Santis sure
would it be good if the President of the
United States were a little more popular
going into the 2018 elections that would
help as well
Rhonda Santos would make an excellent
governor of the state of Florida as I
say here's a down the line conservative
and Gilliam is a radical leftist so
we'll see how all of this plays out but
the only narrative the media really
cares about is not the corruption
narrative to the political narrative
it's the first black governor of Florida
narrative the implication of course
being that America is still deeply
racist and so it'd be a surprise if
Gilliam won the governorship of Florida
which by the way it would not be he has
a serious shot it's a dead even race
okay let's do a couple of things that I
like and then we'll do some things that
I hate will do a federalist paper as
well so things I like we were doing some
Neil Simon this week so Neil Simon did a
play that was made into a movie called
plaza suite with Walter Matthau playing
three different parts in three different
narratives the basic structure of the
play is that there's this hotel suite
and three different plots take place
within it Walter Matthau who's a really
underrated actor Walter Matthau and he's
great in everything you want to see a
great Walter Matthau performance go see
charade which is one of the kind of
great classy movies from the 1960s its
Aubrey Hepburn Audrey Hepburn and and
Cary Grant and James Coburn and George
Kennedy it's a really fantastic cast
it's really a lot of fun and Walter
Matthau plays a great role in that one
as well but here he is in plaza suite
Walter Matthau
and Maureen Stapleton have the plaza
suite
why not because it's Suite 719 at the
Plaza I didn't think you'd want your
pajamas you know I can't sleep without
pajamas I took that into consideration
understand you're one lousy little bag
it's all I asked you to pack Walter
Matthau and Barbara Harris have the
plaza suite
I'm nervous about me you mr. famous
Hollywood producer I haven't changed
since I left Tenafly I made a couple of
pictures that's all
[Music]
Walter Matt Matt was great and of course
he's in he's in a bunch of he's in a
bunch of movies that were Neil Simon
movies basically because the Odd Couple
was such a massive success so go check
that out okay other things that I like
there's a very good piece today my Bjorn
Lomborg Bjorn Lomborg of course has
become famous as the director of the
Copenhagen consensus sensor and he's
famously well known as a guy who's very
skeptical of a lot of the climate change
claims that are made by folks on the
ardent left and he has a piece today
talking about the solution to climate
change and what it would actually cost
this is something folks on the Left
never want to talk about they want to
talk about the cost of climate change
which is fine and then they use the most
catastrophic sort of numbers to come up
with their their estimates which is not
quite as fine you should really give the
sort of range of outcomes and then talk
about what's the probability of each
outcome before you actually gauge what
the solution is going to be right then
this is what we have to do in policy all
the time we gauge risk and benefit and
risk and reward of every policy so for
example whenever the left says if it
would just save one life then we should
do it that's a really dumb gauge because
pretty much everything would save one
life and virtually everything in the
United States would save one life he's
their 330 million people living in the
United States you can make that case for
banning automobiles it would save one
life we should just ban automobiles well
it would save lives who would also
completely destroy the economy make
business wildly inconvenient destroy a
lot of people's you know happiness and
livelihood but it would save one life
well Malmberg makes clear their actual
costs to a lot of the solutions being
proposed by climate change I would say
alarmists in many cases he says
activists like Worldwatch argue a higher
temperature will make more people hungry
so drastic carbon cuts are needed but a
comprehensive new study published in
Nature climate change led by researchers
from the International Institute for
applied systems analysis has found that
strong global climate action would cause
far more hunger
food insecurity than climate change
itself the scientists used eight global
agricultural models to analyze various
scenarios between now and 2050 these
models suggest on average that climate
change could put an extra twenty four
million people at risk of hunger but a
global carbon tax would increase food
prices and push 78 million more people
into risk of hunger those areas expected
to be most vulnerable are sub-saharan
Africa and India shocking because those
are some of the populous places in
poorest places on earth
trying up 24 million people by
imperiling 78 million people is in very
poor policy inferred similar stories
before in a few short decades climate
policy has often created more damage
than the benefits it attempts to deliver
says beyond long burg 10 years ago a
biofuels craze swept rich countries with
full-throated support of green activists
who held any shift away from fossil
fuels food crops were a place to produce
ethanol and the resulting spike in food
prices forced at least 30 million people
into poverty and 30 million more into
hunger according to UK charity ActionAid
if you want to eradicate hunger there
are more effective ways around 800
million people are undernourished today
mostly because of poverty the single
most significant initiative that could
be undertaken tomorrow is not a policy
that slows the global economy than one
that cuts poverty a global trade deal a
global free trade which of course is
exactly correct he talks about the EU s
climate policy says that will
realistically cost six hundred billion
dollars every year for the rest of the
century and at best it delivers a
trifling temperature reduction of just a
point zero nine degrees Fahrenheit by
the end of the century says forcing poor
companies to reduce emissions does even
more harm because cheap abundant energy
brings prosperity for example activists
argue that Bangladesh should cut coal
expansion now deliver a global climate
benefits worth nearly a hundred million
dollars but the forgone boost to the
Bangladeshi economy will cost about
fifty billion dollars which is why all
of this talk about climate change
solutions is basically a rich people
problem you see a lot of folks in the EU
and the United States talking about it
if you're a person living in a
developing country what you're most
worried about today is ensuring that you
don't die and that your kids don't die
does not say we shouldn't try and come
up with solutions to climate change but
if those solutions involve the suffering
of more people than the actual problem
then you're doing it wrong and you're
doing it wrong okay time for a couple of
things that I hate
okay so couple of things that I hate so
there's a report today that sexually
transmitted diseases are on the rise in
the United States according to a new
data from the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention in fact nearly
2.3 million cases of chlamydia gonorrhea
and syphilis were diagnosed in the u.s.
in 2017 surpassing the record set in
2016 by more than 200,000 according to
CDC scientists experts say many factors
have contributed to the rapid rise of
the biggest one maybe less frequent
condom use it's less clear whether
dating apps like tinder have contributed
in some way to the spread of STDs though
some researchers think they have you
want to know why there are more STDs
because people are being more
promiscuous Wow Wow that I know that was
a shock to you I know that you just had
that blew you one out that one blew you
out of your seat I know when you say
people are being more promiscuous and
having more random sex with random
strangers without protection that that
raises the rate of STDs I know that
you've been told by feminism that this
is a great enrichment to human life that
you've been told by by a variety of
folks on the social left that more and
diverse view diverse forms of sex is not
going to have any cost it's just going
to enrich human happiness turns out
giant fail dr. Gail Bolan director of
the division of STD prevention says we
have seen a steep and sustained increase
over the last five years usually they're
absent flows but the sustained increase
is very concerning we haven't seen
anything like this for two decades in
the past the majority of syphilis
infections were seen in gay men bisexual
men and other men who have sex with men
Pollan told NBC News I'm confused with
that third category is the area said gay
men and bisexual men and other men who
have sex with men I'm not sure that's
categories right there
more recently there have been increases
among heterosexual men and women
including among pregnant women which
means we're starting to see these
infections in their babies well my guess
is that if you are starting to see an
increase what that means that there's an
increase in as I say diverse forms of
sexual activity that is leading to
higher rates of transmission among
quote-unquote heterosexuals if that
third category that actually matters
that right other men who have sex with
men but don't consider themselves
bisexual would probably be that third
category Oh in another suspect that
newer drugs may have made HIV less
lethal and that could have contributed
to declines in condom use an Australian
study that followed nearly 17-thousand
gained bisexual men before and after a
campaign
Moute pre-exposure prophylaxis the use
of drugs that protects against HIV
infection found that condom use had
fallen dramatically before the campaign
46 percent of the men studied were using
condoms after only thirty thirty-one
percent were so it's more risky sexual
behavior taken because the media have
been pushing the idea that all sorts of
sex are safe and that we have great
treatments for everything now so well
done media well done for suggesting that
the height of human happiness lies in
sexual promiscuity and that we have
solutions for all of the problems that
you yourself create by putting your
genitalia in places they ought not be
certainly not without protection so well
done all around okay other things that I
hate I'm not sure whether I hate this
when I sort of think that it's hilarious
so US District Court Judge Gregory woods
was not having attorney Kafani in the
chromeless defense of his clients Jamal
Russell that a cooperating witness was
not a reliable source of information as
per Donald Trump so the New York Daily
News reported that Russell was being
tried for a conspiracy to deal crack and
carrying a firearm in connection with
dealing crack you know what's funny
yesterday mana fort was convicted
nakooma said he was referring to the
trial of trump's former campaign chair
pol mana fort and the crew knows
immediately stopped due to an objection
from the court at the bench nakooma
explained he plans to cite trump on the
matter of cooperating witnesses he was
going to cite president from saying that
flipping ought to be illegal
she remembered last week President Trump
said about Michael Kohn that flipping is
a bad practice in ought to be illegal so
apparently this criminal defense layer
said well if the Trump if Trump says it
I agree
people shouldn't be allowed to flip on
my client all of which is why what
President Trump said was really really
dumb on pretty much every level the
judge shut that down because did dumb
argument which is why Trump probably
shouldn't try to make it in court okay
time for a federalist paper so back to
founding principles and a little bit of
uplift on this day of dark media
coverage so Federalist 43 by James
Madison this particular case makes this
particular Federalist paper makes the
case for federal jurisdiction over a
variety of issues including copyright
the nation's capital and to admit new
states among others the feds also have
the ability to guarantee a Republican
form of government the Federalist Papers
says in a Confederacy founds it on
Republican principles and composed of
Republican members the superintendent
government are clearly to possess
authority to defend the system against
aristocratic or monarchical innovations
the more intimate the nature of such a
union may be the greater interests have
the members in the political
institutions of
each other in other words the United
States has an interest in ensuring that
Montana doesn't become a monarchy the
feds also have the capacity to intervene
and put down insurrection within a state
why well this is an interesting point
the existence of a right to interpose
will generally prevent the necessity of
exerting it so this is a very early
iteration of peace through strength
right if the government has the power to
shut down insurrection people are not
going to actually engage in insurrection
that tell us of the case that people
have made in favor of the Second
Amendment an armed population is a
population safe from tyranny because the
government is less likely to attempt
tyranny on an armed population it's also
why the United States should remain
strong militarily people abroad are less
likely to challenge us if we know we can
curb stomp them anytime we please and
the basically it's Madison making that
case with regard to domestic
insurrection Madison also makes the case
for being able to amend the Constitution
he says the useful alterations will be
suggested by experience could not but be
foreseen it was requisite therefore that
a mode for introducing them should be
provided the mode preferred by the
convention seems stamped with every mark
of propriety it guards equally against
that extreme flexibility which would
render the Constitution two immutable
and that extreme difficulty which might
perpetuate its discovered faults in
other words it's hard to pass an
amendment but it's meant to be hard to
pass an amendment but we have a way to
pass amendments so we can adjust the
Constitution Madison and the founders
believes in the amendment process
specifically because they were not
afraid of a runaway convention this has
been one of the objections used to the
so-called convention of states the idea
that you can have basically three fifths
of the states get together and declare a
convention in order to add amendments to
the Constitution of the United States
it's supported by people like me and
Mark Levin there's a convention of
states program in article five
convention of states program and one of
the worries has been the idea of a
runaway convention but it's very hard to
pass a constitutional amendment in any
case and the prospect of a runaway
convention was discounted by the people
who wrote the provision and I think for
a good reason
okay we'll be back here tomorrow with
all the latest updates I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018